today in the biomedical field
information is everything be it genomic
research or Precision medicine you need
all the latest updates on your variants
of interest and you need them now
the problem is keyword-based search
systems don't always work
this is because variants are written in
different ways
additionally challenging is that
variants are mentioned in all parts of
an article
this is why we created lit bar a
database built from over 35 million
biomedical Publications including full
text and supplementary materials with
smart AI we map different variant names
into single Concepts narrow down your
search results with keywords
or by article section journal and year
filters
or directly across litvar data from your
scripts through our apis
litvar helps you stay at the top of your
research try litvar now
[Music]